South Koreans are among the estimated 4
billion people worldwide who will cast
ballots this year and unlike in the past
the National Assembly has made it
illegal for political campaigns to use
deep fake content 90 days before the
election to give viewers time to
consider their authenticity the term
deep fake is a combination of deep
learning and fake and refers to AI
generated content that's often designed
to mislead in the lead to the 2022
presidential polls deep fakes featured
but mostly to generate humor or
Intrigue candidates used avatars to
answer simple questions and held news
conferences in the metaverse since then
however the technology has evolved and
become more prevalent Clips such as
these can be customized for a price or
even produced by novices as you'll see
later in our report def fakes are also
impacting world leaders in December a
student posed a question to Russian
President Vladimir Putin as his AI
generated double and last week voters in
New Hampshire received calls from a
voice pretending to be US President Joe
Biden discouraging them from
participating in the
primaries voting this Tuesday only
enables the Republicans in their quest
to elect Donald Trump again the White
House moved quickly to confirm Biden not
make the recordings it's prompted
concerns about the impact defects can
have in the leadup to elections this is
just the first bite in the Apple not
only for South Korea for other countries
who take the free and fair elections
very s seriously for the longevity of
the liberal democracy the the measures
may not be perfect in their first
attempts but uh they have to be tried so
that the the uh deficiencies have to be
disc discovered in South Korea deep
fakes can be used in campaigning ahead
of the 90-day window as long as they are
clearly identified but much work lies
ahead to disturb the work of actors
outside of official campaigning who are
seeking to confuse and deceive blurring
the lines between what is real and what
is not Unis Kim alera
Soul make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from alaz
here
out